I'm Liz Keleher, I'm a program
manager and I work here at Udacity.
I was a classroom teacher for ten years.
And now, since leaving the classroom and
working for ed tech companies for
about the past five years and
been working side by side with
programmers in what you might
call tech adjacent roles.
And I still have had that
underlying lack of confidence and
I feel a little intimidated
to ask questions,
because I'm not sure if I'm
asking the right questions.
And so I've just really felt that
maybe I'm being inefficient by not
understanding more about the world
of programming, so I really wanted
to jump in and try to learn, really,
to just be better at what I do.
And also, I'm a business owner, and
I own a couple of writing stores, and
we have a website that I've been able
to just jump in there and use some of
my new HTML and CSS skills to work
on it, and make it more appealing.
The more you can find out about
the different career options
there are the better.
We don't work in a world where you have
to pick one path and stick in it for
the rest of your life, in fact
a lot of things have blurred lines.
But you can also work in places where
you may be one thing on paper but
you're getting your hands into
a lot of other areas, too.